[Música]
colombia vino a la izquierda con la
elección de gustavo petro como próximo
presidente y los resultados de los
comicios generaron reacciones mixtas
entre la población el mandatario
saliente e iván duque aseguró que habrá
una transición transparente y eficaz
sigue la atención en ecuador por la
llegada de más integrantes de grupos
indígenas a la capital para manifestarse
contra el aumento en los precios del
combustible aún no hay sintonía para
comenzar el diálogo que evite una
profundización de las protestas el
estado de excepción fue extendido de 3 a
6 provincias
bajo la justicia hondureña condenó a más
de 22 años de prisión al responsable del
asesinato de la líder ambientalista
berta cáceres el acusado fue sentenciado
como coautor intelectual del crimen
bienvenidos a esta misión con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
colombia donde la ciudadanía está
dividida tras la victoria de gustavo
petro el primer presidente de izquierda
que tendrá esta nación petro cano con
más del 50% de los votos pero su
contrincante el populista rodolfo
hernández consiguió un 47 por ciento una
radiografía de la división que vive
colombia y que el nuevo mandatario
tendrá que enfrentar el informe es de
marina sardina
colombia despertó con resaca electoral
después de una noche de espontáneas
celebraciones en las calles tras
conocerse la victoria de la izquierdista
gustavo petro nuevo presidente electo
del país y somos muchos los que creímos
en eso los que teníamos la esperanza
wow
se hizo realidad junto a su fórmula en
la vicepresidencia francia márquez
enarbolaron la bandera de un cambio por
la paz y la reconciliación de una nación
extremadamente polarizada una
representación que movilizó a millones
de colombianos con la participación
electoral más masiva de su historia al
58 por ciento casi había visto en este
país un cambio que puede ser un cambio
total
para mí pero no es todo porque petro es
una persona que está con los pobres no
es orgulloso petrolera todos los pobres
mientras los ricos le quitan a los
pobres las expectativas sobre los
próximos cuatro años de gobierno de
petro son casi tan altas como la
incertidumbre recibo con mucha
incertidumbre puesto que los planes de
gobierno del señor gustavo petro son ya
sido poco incoherentes
solo pedimos que se respete la
constitución las libertades la libre
empresa porque así es la única forma en
que colombia puede salir adelante pero
el domingo en colombia triunfó el cambio
y tanto los opositores del ex
guerrillero del m-19 como los servidores
de su oponente el populista rodolfo
hernández aceptaron los resultados no
era mi candidato pero orar por el poder
haré mucho por él para que nos lleve a
una mejor colombia un cambio total
ahora petro tiene todas las miradas
puestas sobre el primer gobierno de
izquierda la llegada de gustavo petro a
la presidencia colombiana confirma la
tendencia de izquierda que se ha
impuesto en los gobiernos de otras
naciones en el continente como argentina
méxico o chile
más temprano conversamos con humberto
vex profesor en el centro de estudios
internacionales del colegio de mexico e
historiador que nos explicó cuál es el
perfil dentro de la izquierda al cual
pertenece el presidente electo
creo que el perfil de petro no encaja en
la visión tradicional del escartín o
american mac como una izquierda chavista
como una izquierda bolivariana el
triunfo de petró junto con el triunfo de
boric en chile e incluso con el triunfo
junto con el triunfo de lópez obrador en
méxico hace tres años marque yo creo que
un nuevo giro progresista en la región
latinoamericana pero con una crítica muy
distinta al esquema bolivariana no se
trata por ejemplo de hacer
nacionalizaciones no parece haber
tampoco una amenaza a la democracia
electoral se trata más bien de un tipo
de política progresista que dentro de
ciertos límites tratar de reinventar la
socialdemocracia para la región
en ecuador las manifestaciones en contra
del gobierno de guillermo lasso por los
elevados precios de los combustibles
cumplen una semana el presidente aumentó
de tres a seis en las provincias con
estado de excepción y las negociaciones
para resolver la crisis aún no inician
andrés granadillo nos cuenta más
una semana de protestas contra el
gobierno de guillermo lasso el
movimiento indígena denuncia represión
policial nosotros estamos tratando de
reagruparnos anoche una brutal represión
de parte de la policía nacional que
nosotros no podemos permitir así como
ponen ese tan gran piquete de policías y
militares que persiguen a los ladrones
que persigan a los a los delincuentes
comunes que perciban a esos que se roban
la plata del pueblo ecuatoriano uno de
los manifestantes en su intento de
llegar a quitó de la capital perdió la
vida al caer a una quebrada aunque según
sus compañeros no fue debido a los
enfrentamientos según la alianza
indígena 61 personas han resultado
heridas 5 con daños en los ojos debido a
las balas de goma el presidente
guillermo lasso anunció un pequeño
aumento en un subsidio mensual que se
paga a los más pobres así como un
programa para aliviar la deuda de
quienes tienen préstamos de los bancos
estatales pero persiste en mantener el
estado de excepción
estamos atendiendo las legítimas
demandas ciudadanas
su respuesta más violencia nuevas
amenazas y atacar a quitó no podemos
permitir que unos pocos violentos
impidan trabajar a millones de
ecuatorianos las marchas se originaron
para protestar contra la carestía de los
combustibles los precios han subido
fuertemente desde 2020 casi duplicando
el del diésel de 1 a 190 dólares por
galón y aumentando de 175 a 255 dólares
el de la gasolina el gobierno sostiene
estar abierto a un diálogo y aceptó la
convocatoria de varias organizaciones de
la sociedad civil para ejercer de
mediadores
en honduras la justicia cuando de nuevo
22 años y 6 meses de prisión al
empresario roberto david castillo como
coautor intelectual del asesinato de la
ambientalista berta cáceres el 2 de
marzo de 2016 cáceres fue asesinada a
pesar de contar con medidas cautelares
de la comisión interamericana de
derechos humanos después de denunciar
múltiples amenazas de muerte por
oponerse a la construcción de una
hidroeléctrica sobre el río walk arqué
que afectaría a los integrantes del
pueblo lenca al que ella pertenecía la
familia de cáceres aseguró que se trata
de una pequeña victoria pero no los
satisface por lo que consideran que el
estado de honduras sigue en deuda para
nosotros es un momento sumamente
importante que es de decir que el
sistema de justicia ya no tiene más
excusas para este no investigar y no ir
sobre el autor intelectual de este
crimen seis años en espera seis años de
excusas seis años de mentiras seis años
verdad para proteger a una de las
familias más poderosas de honduras
familia está la sable para los cuales
nosotros seguimos exigiendo a
investigación y enjuiciamiento en temas
migratorios méxico registró en 2021 más
de 130.000 solicitudes de asilo de
refugiados lo que corresponde a la
tercera cantidad más alta del mundo de
acuerdo con la acnur y tapachula es la
ciudad que más recibe solicitudes
lo conocieron en el camino y lo apodaron
bob marley su nombre real es marcos
amador y es un hondureño que escapó de
su país el pasado 8 de junio para evitar
que las maras reclutarán a su hijo axel
para adelante para atrás de pagar en
puerta baja a mi hijo
lo quería meter a la mala fuerza y la
verdad las cosas que nosotros siempre
hemos sido personas honradas honestas y
trabajadoras y no acepto es obvio para
él
tras salir de honduras marcos y axel
cruzaron guatemala en autobuses hasta
arribar al albergue el buen pastor en
tapachula
[Música]
cuando se siente bien ya salir de su
país porque sabiendo que está peligrosa
el país jon morse viene a emigrar aquí
también porque es un poco difícil pasar
lo que no ha pasado
porque hay alguno quieren que no se me
tapan días y uno no quiere eso porque
uno quiere un futuro para su vida
marcos y axel tienen dos opciones para
cumplir su meta de llegar a eeuu esperar
meses mientras se tramita una visa
humanitaria que le otorgue estatus legal
de refugiado o aventurarse en una
caravana de miles de migrantes con la
cual evite ser aprehendido por las
autoridades de inmigración y ser
eventualmente deportado
marcos le apuesta al trámite de la visa
humanitaria sin importar que el proceso
se demore hasta seis meses en dar frente
a los acostamos a las dos nos levantamos
a las tres de la mañana y armamos
nuestro grupo que traemos y lo vendimos
caminando que lo tenga
los papeles para cruzar para el otro
lado porque esa es la idea
las solicitudes de asilo en méxico las
otorga la comisión de ayuda para los
refugiados comar un organismo que de las
130.000 peticiones que recibió en 2021
sólo pudo tramitar 38 mil menos del 30
por ciento por lo que para marcos y su
hijo gran parte del sueño americano
dependerá de la suerte
así finalizamos esta emisión de noticias
les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros que
volvemos en breve
[Música]